do you know how much of a cult you have
to be in to believe him when there's
hundreds of pages of evidence against
him do you know how insane you have to
be to believe that guy I guarantee that
not a single person in that room or any
Maga Republican who says he's innocent
has read the indictment I'd put anything
on it I really would you would be wise
not to believe a single word that comes
out of Donald Trump's mouth because
that's a man with everything to lose of
course he's going to say whatever he has
to say to keep himself out of prison I
guess he's missing the point which
is he doesn't seem to understand what a
political persecution is I'm telling
mother persecution be it through
prosecution or through any other means a
political prosecution in this case would
would not necessarily mean that the
person didn't do anything wrong when
Stalin would have his show trials it it
was it wasn't uh the case that the
people he brought up on show trials had
not done anything wrong it's that the
charges were trumped up